how are you
i'm doing good how about yourself i am
doing well and i can say that not only
did i love season one but i loved season
two
so thank you thank you
i'm curious because this show was not
based on source material and no one knew
who these characters would be or what to
expect from them the audience
went into the first season with no
expectations so
when did you realize how much of a
success the show had become and that it
was
connecting with viewers globally i mean
that it's just still wild to me that you
know all around the world
people are connecting and resonating and
just
absolutely you know being big fans of
never have i ever because the never have
i ever fandom is very real
but the biggest thing that like shocks
me is that
like how like how crazy it is you know
like
i can't you know possibly process 40
million
individual people that's like a lot of
people right
so it's pretty awesome to just you know
hear all the
you know feedback from around the world
which i haven't even been around the
world i don't know
many people that have done all those
countries but hey it's really cool
the translate button on all social media
apps is
amazing
there's something for everyone in this
show it's easy to find something to
connect to or someone to connect
with what do you most connect to is it
something directly to relate
directly related to your character or is
it one of the other characters
yeah i think honestly i think the thing
i connect most with
is davey's story in relation to just
her wanting to be and this is more
actually about season two
but you know her wanting to be this
person that is good
even though she's like really struggling
and she's trying and it's not working
out like she's
not trying to hurt people that's
something i definitely related to
when i was younger and now in general
just
always trying to be perfect whether it
comes to work or
being a perfect you know family member
friend having that pressure
and when it doesn't work out you just
you really overthink it you freak out
about it
and you don't understand necessarily why
things are happening and you have a
little meltdown at the end you know
deeply is somebody who is full of rage
what's it like to find her emotional
levels
is it something that you're always
playing with
it's so fun to find her emotional levels
and when we film
we love to like vary it up like i
guarantee you
there are some takes of some scenes
where davey is like
hotter than you could even imagine and
then there's sometimes where she's just
like oh okay
whatever and i know in season one there
is a lot more rage
throughout as davey but it was like a
little too much so we were like hey hey
davey like you're
here take it down here right now please
so
it is fun to play around with those
levels and i'm so thankful for all the
directors
writers and of course mindy kaling and
lang fisher for always
you know letting me play around with
those levels
john mcenroe narrates davey's life if
you could have any
famous person narrate your life who
would you want it to be
i would probably want like just for like
like okay obviously hear me out the
relationship between
mcenroe to davey is because the common
connection is
the rage right like when she rages like
he gets fired up too and they really get
it
i think if i were to have someone
i also would want someone i know right
because like they got to know me a
little
i'd probably ask mindy because i think
mindy and i
understand each other a lot we're two
very separate people with two different
personalities
right just like john mcenroe and davey
but we both understand like you know
always wanting to like go out and like
just seize the day and just always work
hard
even when like things might not work out
our way we just want to keep going
and not take no for an answer so i think
that would be really cool
and also mindy is basically like a
mentor
to me so that would make sense you know
she would tell me like my train no no no
stop stop
stop yeah i think that'd be really
really funny
at the end of season one it felt like
davey was picking ben
and now in season two she's back to not
being sure who she wants to choose
what was your reaction to learning that
she'd be dating them both
this season i mean
is it bad to say i sort of predicted
that
davey this is davey as john mcenroe says
this decision required very little
thought and she's a very smart girl
in certain aspects in other aspects not
so much
so yeah honestly it was like okay
all right we're doing this let's see
where this goes
and let's see how quickly davey messes
this up because
obviously she's going to do you think
that you would be
more decisive in choosing one or the
other than
than she is or do you feel like she sort
of makes the right choice at least in
the beginning to
test out her options just the waters
i don't even know because i don't feel
like i would be in that position where
i had two guys like me or i like two
guys like
i would probably just be in the position
of no guys
no people no people at all anyone cause
love is dead 20-21
tv doesn't have a problem when it comes
to kissing boys it seems to
more be you know that she has a problem
maintaining relationships with boys so
how do you view her love life this
season
how do you approach those scenes is it
fun to do
those scenes it's so fun when it's like
a scene of darren or jaren because
they're just great scene partners but
i like to remind myself that this is
like a 15 year old girl like she's
trying to figure out what she likes
right
so it sorta actually makes a lot of
sense that she's 100 comfortable
kissing these guys but without any
reflection as to like
oh wait like maybe i should like think
about what i'm doing i should just like
kiss him instead maybe i should just
like stop him and say whoa
ben wait i think we should break up like
imagine she just
she just you know interjected in that
conversation conversation and just said
hey uh ben really great that you broke
up with shira
really great that you're uh eating with
your parents now
but we gotta break up or if she went to
back student just said like
no you didn't show me a real date you
lost your chance bud bye
would have been cool would have made for
a short season though
so here we are and she's a teenager so
there has to be drama
of course yeah of course of course
well obviously anything spoilery i would
hold till it's no longer a spoiler
so i'm curious that moment where davey
and paxton
walk into the dance holding hands after
everything is such a
huge moment for them yes is there also
added pressure and responsibility of
getting that exactly
right for the show just because you know
so many fans are waiting for
that kind of a moment oh 100 i will say
though with that shot i
like when i watch like the screeners of
season two but i thought was really cool
and i didn't notice it
while reading all the scripts and
filming it was when
obviously davey blows up at paxton and
says like
i can't hold your hand forever and then
when she goes to apologize
paxton says i wouldn't want you to hold
my hand
and like they're like beefing and like
you know fighting about that and it's
like ah
joke's on you look at you do folded
hands
i'm not team paxton but i'm just saying
like the irony is really funny i love a
good bit of irony
it there is a little pressure that i
want to make sure it's like perfect
but it's not that much because the
writers
the directors the creative team they've
honestly got it all
on lock like the costumes perfectly set
we got the hair and makeup everyone
looks great
the writing is just nice and romantic
yet funny and the directors got the
right
like you know positioning the dp's got
the great lighting
like of course the editing with sound
with that song sam smith's love goes on
it's probably my favorite from season
two
i listen to that on repeat a lot but
yeah
with all that combined you're pretty set
i love her dress too i mean was that
something like did you know exactly what
her dress would be
from the beginning or did you have to
try like a bunch of dresses on
that was actually the only dress i tried
on and
we just knew right away like that's the
one and the dress didn't have any like
you know there's like those little
crystals on it so it sort of like shines
with the light
those crystals weren't on it but thank
you to
the amazing costume team that we have on
never have i ever because they
like by hand every single one
every single crystal on that dress just
is by hand and salvador perez
who's the head of the costume department
does a great job
honestly like it was so cool to see like
that dress come to life
because it was actually also a long
dress like a gown
with a little train but then we're like
okay we're gonna cut it
we're gonna go for more like the 60s
kind of style we'll put an underskirt to
like poof it out like we really
just made it our own which is really
cool were you surprised that
paxton finally made that big step was
there a conversation about
like did you know going into the season
how the season would end up
or were you surprised when you found how
that moment would play out
yeah i mean we read the scripts like as
they come through
right so we all like you know take it a
little step by steps
as we film and it would make sense like
i remember when we were
filming the actual like scene that's
like that moment where like you know she
gets
feeded by the car and we really do come
full circle about that
we talked about the fact that paxton now
finally realizes that jd is that person
that
believes in him that doesn't think he's
dumb
but also calls him out when he needs to
be called out about
he doesn't the fact that he doesn't try
he needs to try harder
he needs to be better and he's not
pushing himself enough because he
doesn't believe in himself
so i think with all that combined and of
course he was hurt by davey's actions
when he realizes that he gets the moment
to sit down and realize like oh
yeah davey's actually like there for me
sometimes more than i am for myself
which is a little bit of a problem
because you should really be there for
yourself first and foremost it makes
sense why he does come eventually to the
dance
also who doesn't like a good dance that
makes logical sense he's 16 he's in high
school like
go live it up how do you think all of
this will affect things
moving forward for her have you thought
about what any of this would mean for a
season three
yeah i mean i don't know where we're
gonna take it
because i have no idea what shenanigans
davey's gonna get up to i could not have
predicted
myself being in a cricket costume this
season
and that was me doing that dance no
stunt doubles
but i have no idea where that's gonna go
but i think it'll be really cool to see
what davey's like in a relationship like
a real relationship
did you bond with a crooked costume or
did you want to set god
i love that so much we have bonded with
the sweat
that came out of me while dancing in
that because there were no fans
it was real hot
mommy think you either have to be all in
or just want to
completely destroy it oh yeah i went all
in some people
like on set were like why didn't you get
like a body double to do this like what
are you doing
and i'm like no i'm gonna do this and if
anyone tells me after that that wasn't
me
no way no way uh uh
yeah it was like a whole thing we had to
like practice a lot myself
uh ramona and lee for like their
cheerleader bit
and we practiced first like just regular
no costumes
then with just the head-on and then with
the whole thing yeah step by step
do you have your own personal wish list
of things you would still like to
explore with her
to learn more about with her yeah i mean
she's like a 15 year old kid that has
the whole world in front of her
she's got a lot that she can explore i
think it'd be
really cool to just you know maybe see
more of her interests
see more of like the journeys that she
takes or like
the new people that she might meet and
you know of course
everyone loves good relationship drama
but also
the journeys that she takes with her
friends i think those are all really
cool aspects that
could happen you came to the show so new
you know learning about
acting about yourself leading a tv show
how different did season two on the
first day feel
than when you walked onto set the first
day of season one
lots of masks lots of masks that's
number one um lots of half
faces and like of course with
all the copic protocols which is the
reason why we could film
it did make it a little different when
it came to cast and crew bonding
right being able to talk to each other
as often and just you know enjoy each
other's company
a big part of like you know what makes
set so great
and personally my favorite part of the
day is lunch when we get to all just
like sit and eat together
but we couldn't do that so i would say
that's probably the biggest difference
did you feel different i mean just as
from an acting perspective did it feel
like you
you looked at it a different way now
oh i mean i'm a little like more
confident with my skills
midge just like davey has grown up a
smidge i'm a little bit more confident
that i'm not a trash actor um
yeah that is definitely a difference
from season one to two
but it came with still nerves and
pressure of like okay
but you like really have to like nail it
this season you know you don't want to
let anyone
down well i appreciate you talking about
it you bring such heart to the show
and it's just so fun so thank you thank
you no thank you